welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
mandalorian season 2 episode 7 chapter
15
the believer an episode that makes a
true believer out of bill burr
as they murder freedom fighters just
trying to keep the empire from blowing
up more people
as always there were a ton of
interesting details and star wars easter
eggs hidden in this imagery i'm gonna
break down
everything you missed here we go we open
on the carthon chop fields a scrapyard
in which atats at ats are once again
repurposed as cranes as they were on
trask a detail i love
since the artists working on the empire
strikes back based the atation that's on
oakland port cranes so they're coming
full circle
now most of the junk in these yards are
tie fighter parts which makes it a just
punishment for migs maybelle bill burr a
former imp now having to physically
dismantle the hardware of the empire now
a brick vessel floats overhead this is
the same kind that
mayfield mando and the others
infiltrated back in chapter six of last
season the guard droid now is similar to
that new republic's security droid we
saw in that episode
i love how it says you have three
seconds to comply with your new
directive
to comply just like robocop you have 20
seconds to comply
apparently the new republic is set up in
a way so that a recently appointed
outer rim local marshal is allowed to
show up at
any major prison with barely any
explanation and remove a prisoner
yeah that imperial officer was not
joking when he said the new republic is
a mess no wonder the first order got the
jump on them one of the other inmates is
the hassk race we actually saw one of
these little freaky goblins show up on
the new republic prisoner registry
might be the same one because i think if
you look at a lot of those pictures a
lot of them seem to line up with those
bandits and almost got mando and grogu
on tatooine
as well as one of the aqualish who cara
dune just booked on navarro boba fett
got himself a
nice matte paint job notice how his
armor bears the sigils of the myth oh
sorry as i did before but we can also
more clearly now see this jester morel
sigil
that is the name i found in the mandoa
chain code last episode the mentor to
boba's father
jango jango and jaster were part of the
clan called the true mandalorians they
were actually
enemies to the death watch though i
guess those rivalries don't really
matter anymore because they're all dead
but before we continue i want to thank
bessie shoes for sponsoring this
breakdown if you are looking for shoes
that look and feel great keep your feet
dry and temperature controlled
and are super comfortable this is the
way
the scene makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and weatherproof
and way more comfortable than some stiff
old winter boot not today boots
bessie's shoes are super stretchy
they fit like a sock they only weigh 175
grams that's so light you could
practically lift them using just the
force
even if you aren't force sensitive they
are made with the space age dynamics
material so these shoes you can wear
every day in all kinds of weather leave
them by the door and have one less thing
to worry about they're easy to clean
just rinse with water
toss them in the washing machine besties
are also sustainably made with no
animal by-products whether i'm stomping
through puddles or just diving deep on
some mandalorian easter eggs vesti's
keep my feet dry and comfy
i don't want to lose these oh brother i
got my shoe all
wet what was i thinking putting these in
the pool
and losing them hey but you know what my
toes are
totally dry right now there's not a drop
of wetness that i can peel on my toasty
woozies and that must be thanks to these
knit sneakers from bessie thanks guys
and they have an incredible early
holiday sale offer right now don't
procrastinate and wait till the last
minute of your holiday shopping
this is the perfect gift for you and
your loved ones especially for the
upcoming rainy season
get them while they still have sizes and
you can thank me later check them out in
the link below and if you missed the
holiday sale use my code new rockstars
to get 25
off your bessie shoes this episode's
title is the believer which on one level
definitely refers to denjarian in makes
mayfield's chat in the transport cab
mayfeld initially drawn a moral
equivalence between the empire and the
new republic
pride and mando for sticking to his
dogmatic code look i'm just saying
we're all the same but both men change
their beliefs by the episode n
mayfeld remembers the imperial war
crimes that he was ordered to commit and
crimes that took the lives of many of
his own
fellow imperial soldiers memories that
clearly scarred him to this day and he
decides the empire is actually far
worse than the new republic so blow him
up and then mano takes a huge step
he lets go of his face covering rule as
a last resort because something is more
important to him of course finding the
child but i actually think the believer
of this episode title
is that imperial officer valen hess he
is played by awesome character actor
richard brake who played joe chill and
batman begins he was also the night king
in game of thrones just season three and
four
before they changed the actor in season
five and then did all that great stuff
with him in season eight
hess ends as the last true believer of
all these characters he
dies for his world view that the order
the empire brings justifies
all their cruel means and the fact that
he's so convinced
is terrifying because there is some
truth to his depraved mindset
yet this episode tells us that change in
growth is how we survive how we walk
away
meanwhile staying a stubborn believer
leaves you in the dust with a hole in
your chest
then back inside the sleeve one notice
how the hole rotates around them i love
this it accounts for the vessel's
segmented design and orientation
like it needs to do this in atmosphere
to account for the gravity though
presumably when they enter space
whatever artificial gravity that exists
on all star wars vessels should keep
everything oriented
they head to morak where a secret
imperial mining hub collects
rydonium a highly volatile explosive now
rydonian was actually used to kill fair
knocks on annexus and rebels you'll
remember those furnace coming back in
the recent bad batch arc on clone wars
mayfeld says the base is run by
xisb that stands for imperial security
bureau
moff gideon was isb they are kind of the
secret police of the empire they are the
ones who side
uh everyone keep notes they seek out the
disloyalty of the ranks that explains
why hess was iron mando so closely
thenx shan says she's wanted by the isb
and actually the recent bad batch
trailer gives us a hint to why
she was involved in a little rebellion
on kamino for all of you asking yes i do
plan on breaking down that bad batch
trailer just give me some time then
mando asks boba fett if he wants to go
in the base
let's just say they might recognize my
face yep that's because bubba fett is
technically a clone who would have the
same face as
every clone trooper who used to fight
for the empire so a clone trooper faced
showing up would definitely raise some
red flags
mando and mayfeld pull the classic all
disguise ourselves as imps trick
but finally brings a bit of realism to
it oh my god this guy
reeked his gloves are still wet
thank you yeah putting on someone else's
armor would probably smell pretty bad
especially if they are working on a
steamy jungle planet looking at eugene
erso on scarab no way that smelled like
old spice in there you should have spent
that whole third act with a wrinkled
nose
the local boy who looks up at him is
probably the one who alerted the
pirate's
little snitch and those pirates bored
with thermal detonators
director rick famous uses this great
shot following mando out the side window
and then back in the cab and then
without cutting it all through this
follows them up to the roof of the door
so all in one shot we get this nice bit
of scene geography we know where
everyone is so that when we cut back and
forth we don't get too bewildered
but then when the rhidonium gets hot it
flashes the word
warning i translate the auravest because
i love you
i also love how when mando confronts the
pirates he takes their blows with his
imp
armor forgetting he is not wearing
besgar and these blows will hurt
though he does show off some solid spear
throwing skills telling us that when
mando uses that best scar spear
pedro pascal will be well in control and
they are saved by
tie fighters and storm troopers with the
best
aim of any stormtroopers i've ever seen
since mayfield would be recognized by
hess mando makes the big move
of removing his helmet to scan his pedro
pascal-shaped face
the terminal reads id scan required then
access granted and then the menu reads
database equipment personnel transport
armory
and s forces and then gideon's ship
reads light speed cruiser
location sec maybe for secret
or southeastern conference saban is
harboring him
actually star wars theory compared this
with the actual star wars star map to
determine that moff gideon ship
looks like it's near the crime world of
narshada which also appeared in force
unleashed but i wouldn't get too excited
yet that rom koto could be the jedi
grogu linked with just because forces
unleash i don't think is canon really
that chip could also be headed to kamino
which would make sense with dr
pershing's and gideon's cloning goals
with a child
hess asks for mando's tk number that's
the designation for all stormtroopers
but mayfeld covers for him saying his
hearing was damaged at
tanab uh nod to the battle lando
mentions in return of the jedi someone
must have told him about my little
maneuver at the battle of tanev
and then he says come on let's go fill
out those tps reports
so we can go recharge the power cord tps
reports this had to be an ad-lib by bill
byrd tps reports is a nod to office
space the pointless reports that peter
keeps forgetting to fill out you
apparently didn't put one of the new
cover sheets on your tps report but hess
wants a drink
how about a toast to operation cinder
operation cinder that was the name of
the emperor's postmortem plan to take
down as many planets as possible in the
event of its death
using orbital satellites to screw with
planetary atmospheric conditions and
devastate the surface
originally this was brought up in
shattered empire but then it was
explored much further in the battlefront
2 game campaign
mayfeld mentions being ordered to carry
out this mission on the planet vernon
khan a planet that has shown up in lando
stories other star wars properties but
then they found
shoots hess and he and mando shoot their
way out i love these solid screams the
storm
troopers make as they fall to their
deaths
it's fun to point out the famous sound
effect of wilhelm scream in return of
the jedi
and now it seems like the crew the
mandalorian is having fun making their
own generation of wilhelm screams
then mayfeld blows the rhidonium and i
gotta say i really thought that whole
damn was gonna go
right flood the village drown that
little snitch fully
refuting mayfeld's come to jesus
transition this episode but now it's
disney
boba fett eludes the tides by dropping a
seismic charge just like the ones his
papa jango
dropped in the asteroid field when
pursued by kenobi in attack of the
clones
i love how these things sound
[Music]
and the episode ends with mando sending
moff gideon a message with the
same exact threatening words that gideon
delivered to him in episode 7 of last
season
you have something i want
you may think you have some idea what
you are in possession of
but you do not you do not
so in a few moments he will be back with
me he means more to me
than you than you ever know
nando must have a pretty good memory
maybe he wrote these down maybe he just
records everything
just interesting how he knew it word for
word it's like he pulled the episode
script
anyway it has been a busy weekend here
at new rockstars with all the disney
investor day news be sure to watch
all of our breakdowns on this stuff
check out our great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification button follow me eddie voss
follow new rockstars thank you for
watching i have spoken
[Music]
you